both of you have mentioned writers that
have had influences on you and I wanted
to ask both of you what you feel you're
like what legacy do you stand in and
what legacy would you like to leave as
writers that's a scary question because
I don't I don't really think about
legacy although maybe I should you know
at the at my age I know I've I've
recently turned 70 but I still feel like
I'm 16 inside sometimes I feel twelve
people go into the White House thinking
about their legacy so your contribution
I would imagine
or I can assert is broader than many of
our recent presidents so I think it's a
legitimate question it's been kind of
surreal to you know I I mean for a long
time every fantasy it came out was
compared with Tolkien you know if this
is the new Lord of the Rings this is the
heir to Tolkien etc etc and that was
certainly true of my stuff when it came
up he believed in commented on the are
ours and you know the fact that we're
both are ours of course when we sold it
to television you always have to compare
it to that so it was the sopranos and
middle-earth that was how David and Dan
sold it to television but now I find
myself being the one who's referenced
instead of Tolkien this is the new game
of thread this is the black youth Rose
or this is des here's the new church our
Martin is a wait a minute just a new
Joker Martin I wasn't done with big
George our part yet and I'm getting you
know I've got a couple awards that are
like Lifetime Achievement Awards and I'm
wait a minute wait a minute I'm not
doing done achieving I'm certainly not
done with my lifetime so thinking about
legacy and this other stuff is is is
strange but I think like every writer I
would like to be remembered I would like
to hope that the Song of Ice and Fire is
still being read 50 years from now and a
hundred years from now
by which time I hopefully will be around
in my new robot body and able to enjoy
all this acclaim and the continuing
royalties that we'll be generating but
if I can influence other writers and and
help inspire them to do good work the
way people like cocaine and Robert a
Heinlein and Jack Vance and and the
other writers who inspired me did then
I'll I'll be very happy with that I hope
I'm a part of of this this kind of
expansion of what his story I also hope
that that you know at some point we look
back and chocolate remember when we had
this thing called genre you know and you
know I mean growing up in Jamaica I
couldn't afford John her snobbery say I
read whatever book I could steal
everything or whatever book I could find
our borrow and don't return and and one
did that you know it would it would be
you know the railway children or it
would be unit blatant or would be Shogun
and Taipan or it would be sown in a fury
is just whatever I could get my hands on
or tons and tons of x-men and Teen
Titans and just just be glad to have
something to read and and I think it's
it's you know it's something that we
need to sort of move from you know I get
asked about things like cultural
appropriation all the time in the
literature and they an hour's answer
with a question which is how come we
don't have this problem with the crime
people what I'll have is from the crime
writers nearly every turn the wire was
wait you know what what are the crime
writers doing that a literary authors
aren't well they don't know if there's
they don't reclaim you know what it's
it's a they're there things that right
there there's so many things writers
couldn't learn from other writers and
the whole idea of this is a genre
mess with is you deciding this is a kind
of intellectual poverty I'm choosing to
have which is fine knock yourself oh
this would be one ignorant idiot but I
mean a lot of stuff I learned about
literary fiction I learned from you know
like you know episodes 175 to 200 of
x-men you know there are things that
that am I still quote from and they soon
as the Chris Claremont is gonna come
with receipts you know and I nearly
missed my own book signing cousin lining
up for my Mignola it was crazy because
Hellboy rules everything yeah I just to
me it's one thing I learned from from my
teachers is that almost you can learn
from nearly anything and to me any book
is an opportunity for that how people
look at you know the stuff I read that
way as well that it was part of that
sort of you know a way in which we we
tear down boundaries and barriers and
and can learn from anything and no I get
that
genre is [ __ ] and I regret that it's
become such a major part of the
publishing industry today you know when
I was a kid in Bayonne New Jersey and I
started graduate from comic books to
ebooks and we can afford a hardcover
books you know I would take take my
allowance I get a 35 cent paperback but
I bought it from a spinner rack which
was right next to the comic book thing
and wire spinarak
and they didn't have john resections
there everything was all mixed together
so I'm looking for a science fiction
book but I have to go through you know a
couple Mike Hammer books with sexy
covers and then it was a Shakespeare
play and he was a norman vincent peale
and how to win friends and influence
people non-fiction everything was well
mixed together and yeah I mostly read
science fiction fantasy but every once
in a while something would catch my well
here's a historical novel about mice
that looks good I'll take that and
suddenly I'm reading historical fiction
or I'm reading mystery fiction or I'm
reading a classic of literature because
I remember reading the classics
Illustrated comic version I like that so
now I'll try the act
one will be dick and mixing up all of
these genres and subcategories and
subgenres together to my mind was very
healthy but unfortunately the spinning
rack is mostly gone and now we're going
into big bookstores and and it's all
divided into section or we have Amazon
which you know notices our buying habits
and goes up and says here's other books
you're like which are exactly like the
books that we bought last week so it's
it's reinforcing narrower and narrower
reading things when we should be trying
to broaden that you know and I wish I
Mazon would say here's something you
never tried before why don't you try
that instead of just oh you know you you
bought one book by this author here's
another book by the same author Gardner
Dozois on on my my dear friend and
colleague Gordon opposed wha who died
last year we did a number of
deliberately genre busting anthologies
that tried to replicate the spinner rack
will we take a very broad subject like
warriors and we'd invite science fiction
writers mystery writers
mainstream writers literary writers
Romance Writers whatever and just write
something about a warrior anytime place
real imaginary and we got some great
stuff by that and hopefully introduced
readers you know they would say Oh
Stephen King is in and I'll buy it for
him and then they would read a story by
Joe Lansdale who they'd never heard of
before or you know some other writer
that they'd never heard of and the
people who bought it for the mystery
writers would encounter historical
writers and we love doing that that were
we're very proud of those anthologies
but we need to we need to get past this
categorization of genre and some runners
are good and bad it's it once again
going back to Faulkner the human heart
in conflict with itself that that's what
makes a good story not whether it has a
spaceship or a dragon in it or or a
gumshoe Private Eye or whatever I wanted
to speaking of the human heart and
thinking about it in a different way I
think you all are in a unique moment
with literature and this intersection
between literature and what ultimately
ends up on television
the Game of Thrones trilogy right the
trilogy right sure with extra the
trilogy right you we were talking right
before we came down here about how its
unfolding beyond the book in some ways
on television on pace with you writing
right what's gonna be on me it's out
page it's gone beyond so there's this
real I mean it takes to me an amazing
heart to be able to write with that kind
of audience peeking over your shoulder
right the the the the television
audience
the literary audience the Amazon
audience that are trying to sell a
particular into the series that's not
over yet those kinds of concerns are a
little different than I think writers to
Jenners generations ago had to deal with
and I and I wanted to know if you could
speak to that experience and what that
what that's been like for you well it's
not entirely comfortable I mean in in
some ways it's great that so many people
were eager for the next book and so many
people were invested in one no but to
the extent that I feel the people
looking over my shoulder it it it slows
me down it troubles me it's it's as if
somebody was actually peering over my
shoulder and you know when the writing
is going well that vanishes I mean but
when when I'm really on a roll I'm in
Westeros I mean I mean I'm gonna scene
with you know whatever character I'm
writing about Danny or Tyrion I'm I'm
inside their skin I'm looking out
through their eyes I'm seeing who
they're seeing and thinking what they're
thinking and trying to do it and and
there are no editors there is no TV show
there are no people looking over my
shoulder and I'm not worried about the
reception I'm just trying to say okay
what would he do then what would he say
now oh how do I describe the scene more
vividly two people can picture where he
is and we're
standing and and you know what whether
it's cold or hot or the central feelings
all that I lose myself in a moment I
lose myself in the scene anything that
takes me out of that in terms of the
awareness of the outside world and
outside pressures is is bad in that
sense on the other hand it's undoubtedly
great that well you know when the book
comes out that millions and millions of
people are eagerly gonna rush out and
buy it I mean obviously that's good you
know I've been I've been at the other
side of that too I've had a long career
and a lot of people don't quite realize
that but you know I was writing and
publishing novels and true stories one
20 years before I even began Game of
Thrones and there's been another 20
years since but back in the old days I
had my share of doing autograph parties
at Walden books where nobody came or you
know you sit there for three hours and
then someone comes up and you're all
eager and they say we're to cook books
[Music]
[Laughter]
thankfully that doesn't happen anymore
if anything I have the opposite problem
of that too many people come and then I
think I'm gonna have a stroke at day if
the fourth hour of signing books but you
know it's it's it's a strange feeling it
is a strange feeling